après la bûche de noël classe à la
traditionnelle galette des rois tous les
ans ce sont près de 2000 galettes
préparées sur le mois de janvier dans
cette boulangerie à houdan c'est une
tradition c'est celle gâteau
de début d'année qui passe bien qu'ils
avaient une nuit les gens qui
aujourd'hui est compliquée pour les
réunir mais ouais je pense que c'est le
gâteau un peu festif pour réunir les
gens souhaiter la bonne année j'aime
bien la tradition la trachée fans et
c'est festif
aucun jeu se réunir et d'affaires lazard
la méthode est artisanale
un exercice qui demande une grande
précision car ici qu'on ne plaisante pas
avec la galette après la préparation de
la pâte qui doit reposer une journée la
confection demande une précision
chirurgicale
à commencer par la garniture pour dames
en farine
beurre sucre glace chantier et rome
[Musique]
le lendemain du coup après avoir l'avoir
mis en sac je vais lui donner quatre
tours dans la journée donc deux tours
ainsi que deux au tour 2 heures après le
temps que la pas trop pose bien et le
lendemain ensuite je lui donne un
cinquième tour je procédais du coup au
détail des galettes une fois toutes les
galettes sont détaillées sur le patron
là je vais les mettre sur gris et les
stocker au frigo une petite demi-heure
avant de les garnir pour la galette à
l'eau ce qui va permettre
aux deux disques de feuilletage de
scolaires entre eux et ensuite on va
procéder au garnissage
[Musique]
affaires mises en place là je vais
procéder à la soudure du coût des
galettes donc c'est sans rien de plus et
on est une école juste entre elles c'est
le lot qui va faire le reste du travail
et ensuite un petit coup de d'horreur
[Musique]
cette année la galette a une
particularité en plus elle est solidaire
si le client une fève de tels
restaurateurs ils se présentent chez le
restaurateur le restaurateur pour lui
offre pas le cocktail de bienvenue pour
le repas qui sera consommée chez lui
lorsqu'on voit même une petite fête en
fête le client aura du coup une petite
remise de 10% en fait sur le choix sur
le sur la pièce de son choix en ce
moment je suis un commerçant vous voilà
vous avez un avantage chez un autre et
je trouve que c'est hyper important
surtout dans une petite ville comme la
nôtre consommer artisanale et locales
tout en mangeant un produit de qualité
un cocktail qui ravit les clients comme
les boulangers qui peuvent faire jusqu'à
10 % de chiffre d'affaires
supplémentaire sur cette période